so one of the things i i almost tweeted
out the other day and this is something
i do feel
politicians
take credit for things all the time that
have nothing to do with and they take
blame for things they had nothing to do
with too yeah the problem is that
there's like this myth that you know oh
i put you in charge and all of a sudden
like you know like you're you're going
to make it better because you're a nice
person and the other person's not a nice
person it's like no the problem is that
you have deep thorny problems and really
ineffective bureaucracies that aren't
delivering and if i put like a different
person in charge like you still have a
lot of the same problems and and so this
is one of the big reasons why things are
getting so nasty here is that we're all
just fed up and frustrated
like value's not being delivered you
have these completely impersonal
bureaucracies that are just you know
failing and then
and we act like it's like you know why
it's failing because that person's an
[ __ ] yeah and then we put you in
charge and then it's like oh you mean
it's still failing oh [ __ ] and then like
and then like you know i mean phillip
howard called us like we're playing you
lose i lose you lose i lose while the
people lose right um and during that
entire period
our trust is just going down and down
and down and down
down and down
and that's where we are
now
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone welcome back to forward
that's funny isn't it
what we are going to talk about today i
think has been the dominant piece of
news i've seen over the last number of
days where there is this big concern
fear picture that i happen to think is
relatively accurate
that we are going to see
donald trump versus joe biden in the
rematch in 2024.
there was an op-ed in the washington
post a couple of weeks ago
saying that this is going to be the
match up and also that there's a concern
that
our democracy
and this is going to seem hyperbolic to
a lot of people
but that our democracy
may not actually still be in place post
24 and bill maher had this very very
widely circulated video about
essentially the same topic that if you
think that trump's going to come back
and play fair and accept results
he won't and so
there's a great chance he wins straight
up but there's a great chance that
regardless of whether he wins or loses
he's going to say he won and that could
result in
widespread political violence riots
protests strife
the next gen civil war
uh
what you just said is terrifying um
so but let's break it down we'll share
the video about bulmar did like a 15
minute rant
last friday if you're listening this
right yeah yes and most of the things
that he said i totally agree with i mean
some of these things are objective
reality to the extent that a reality is
an objective thing anymore but i guess
that's one of the major problems
so one of the facts i outlined in my
book is that
our relationship with the media
might be the defining element of the
political parties at this point where 69
of democrats have high trust in media
and only 15 of republicans do right
if you're an independent
it's 36 percent
so if you have 85 percent of republicans
who think the media is [ __ ]
and a lot of those people also think the
election stolen
[Music]
that trump should still be president
fair and square
and then they come back in 24 led by
trump there's going to be kind of a
revenge just deserts
payback
motivation for many of them and then if
they're told that trump wins
regardless of what
the vote totals look like they're
probably going to be
uh
there to enforce what they see as their
guy's rightful victory
so
listening that video was like listening
to you off the record and this first
time we're talking about on the record
so he made three predictions he was like
trump's gonna run for president 2024
he's going to win the republican
nomination and the third one no matter
what happens he's just going to announce
that he won
and the other stats he said was they'll
be backed up by
people he's putting in place and we talk
about that but also what you just said
two-thirds of republicans believe the
election was stolen
and 21 million believe the use of force
is necessary to restore or order um and
about half republicans believe we should
split from the union or should have two
different states of the united states um
you know we can talk about what the heck
that would look like i mean i have no
way anyway that was like that that was
the bill maher yeah for sure so let's
break it down in order
does donald trump run again would be the
first domino
let's see he's raised well over 100
million dollars as of a couple months
ago he's having rallies around the
country there's really
little reason i can see for him not to
run yep the only two things i could see
that would keep it from happening are
number one health his health yeah
because he is in his mid 70s though
apparently someone told me he's lost
some weight lately good for him i guess
and then number two would be if there is
some kind of legal trouble or
entanglement uh that people talk up
sometimes that he might be indicted
about this and that right i find it
dubious that he's going to wind up in
that kind of legal trouble
so in my mind yes he does run again
and so then the second part of the
puzzle is does he win the republican
nomination right and that seems to be a
big yes
last i saw he had 65 percent
approval support among republicans who
would decide this thing
and of the other
contenders
one of them nikki haley has just said
publicly i will not run against trump
that's one good way to stay on is his
good side
and another person said in a private
event that i somehow heard about ron
desantis said that he also would not run
against trump if trump decides to run
and ron's public statements are
you know
make that seem very believable right and
so if trump does run who would be his
opponents in the republican party
mike pence
chris christie
larry hogan
[Music]
some other people
tbd maybe kasich i don't know but the
major contenders in my mind of nikki
haley and ron desantis i do not believe
would run against trump so if he does
run i think he rolls
through
the christie pence hogan
group yeah and becomes the republican
nominee well it's not like a news cycle
is going to derail him ernie there's no
uh
you know like scandal
at this point that's going to change our
opinion on donald trump you know what
i'm saying like what would knock him out
i don't know probably not and that was
bill maher's point too you somehow how
the anti-trump
wing of the party has been essentially
dismantled knocked out um and the
republicans should win the midterms
kevin mccarthy should be speaker house
if that happens in 2022 like he'll have
the infrastructure in place to pretty
much run train on the republican party
um this sounds scary it is scary but
it's also not that hyperbolic i think
it's pretty
if you break it down it seems very very
not just plausible but likely
okay
so here's another issue to drop
donald trump becomes the republican
nominee does he get his social media
accounts back
because at that point it's very
difficult to take
them away from someone who's literally
the nominee of the major party yeah so
he probably gets social media back
he's running
and now let's take a step back for a
moment to what the political landscape
may look like then
now it's early days but the democratic
administration is not doing so great in
terms of the public
eye
where the last polling i saw put joe in
the low to mid 40s in terms of rating
approval ratings are low for joe biden
and dropping dude i mean by the numbers
right now now it happens sometimes
before midterms and like there are some
historical present there but it's not
great
well one of the things and we can talk
about this where
uh
so it's been a rough number of weeks or
months for joe and the democrats
um now can you imagine them rebounding
in a way that everyone's like oh this is
going great i mean let's say they pass
the infrastructure bill they pass
reconciliation a couple of things start
going right i think their numbers could
stabilize but it's very difficult for me
to imagine like a complete dynamic sea
change where i i think that
uh
i think that there is a vibe that the
dems are giving off that right now
they're kind of fractious and
and it's not uh
it's not happening for them i mean again
it could change but let's play out
what's likely to happen in the days to
come there's going to be
a bit of a at a minimum even if things
pass there's going to be a bit of a
traffic jam legislatively down the
stretch of the end of this year because
they're trying to get a lot of things
done and they have to raise a debt
ceiling and and um
avoid default before year end which is
going to complicate life because in the
senate i don't and this is an inside
baseball thing but just to reprise you
of what happened they punted on it and
temporarily raised the debt ceiling
until december but then chuck schumer
decided to stick his thumb in the eye of
every uh
yeah and and then uh and then mitch
mcconnell afterwards was like well [ __ ]
that like we're not gonna play ball with
you guys again by year end and so for
the democrats to elevate the debt
ceiling themselves they'd have to do
what's called a budget reconciliation
and apparently that process is a super
pain in the neck
where one of the things i saw said that
it actually will take like two weeks for
them to raise the debt ceiling be a
budget reconciliation because of the
technicalities and i was like what
so uh and so you can add that into the
traffic jam
elements
[Music]
if you're like me and zack and a lot of
other people it's kind of hard to eat
healthy you know you just keep ordering
the same stuff over and over again you
know it's not that great for you you're
like i'll get after this tomorrow one
thing you can do that's going to help
you immediately is get athletic greens
where it's one scoop it's got 75
vitamins minerals
it's athletic and green you know what i
mean you put it in you mix it with some
water you drink it and then you feel
like you had something nourishing and
sustaining that's going to make you feel
much better about
your day and then you do this every day
and then you're off to the races either
literal or figurative
this works for athletes for moms for
weekend warriors which is essentially
what i am at this point
so if you want to give it a try
athletic greens is going to give you an
immune supporting free one-year supply
of vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase if you visit
athleticgreens.com
yang today you'll be glad you did again
visit athleticgreens.com yang take
control your health be good to your body
give athletic greens a try
[Music]
so there's still going to be this
on this dynamic where you don't feel
like things are coming out of dc next
fall is 2022 and traditionally the in
power party loses
10 15 18 seats in that instance if you
look at the house of representatives
everyone's up for re-election
and
right now the democrats have a five seat
edge
i looked at the
markets and then they say there's about
a 75 chance that republicans retake the
house so people see it as very very
likely
and i will say i also see it as very
very likely
because
democrats lost 12 13 seats in 2020 yeah
against trump
now things aren't humming for democrats
so logically like which way do you think
it's gonna swing when again the in power
party traditionally loses right 12 15
seats
so then kevin mccarthy becomes the
speaker of the house circa 2022
not much is going to happen
out of washington for the next two years
because you know a dysfunctional will be
back gridlock will be back in full force
and then
trump's storming back 24
who do the democrats run against
donald trump
i'm assuming they're going to run joe or
kamala
and if joe doesn't run he like would be
the heir apparent would be kamala is
that
i'm assuming that's the common sense
amongst the party
joe biden
plus is
incumbent president
defeated trump already
reasonable case
downsides
will be 81 years old at that point
easily the oldest president to be
running for office
and
his numbers might not be that strong
he
he risks being a visual emblem
of
kind of a declining establishment
i mean that like that that's the risk
for democrats what you want to do is
have someone who's a bit fresher and so
you pass the baton to kamala harris
problem
kamala consistently polls four to five
points worse than joe yeah and kamala
has a similar profile to hillary clinton
and hear me out on this politically i'm
hearing you out so kamala harris is a
blue state senator of a deep blue state
in california
it's very very tv oriented state
she then runs for president and
underachieves
loses
and then gets appointed by the person
who defeated her to a very elevated post
you could use those words on hillary
clinton or
kamala harris and they they both are
correct
and then
when that person decides to run for
president that person
struggles in part because they don't
have that organic a connection to a lot
of people like it you know they're in
that position because the person that
defeated them
appointed them and so then they're
they're getting presented as like oh you
know this person like you love them and
everyone's like wait do we love this
person
like like when did this happen
so
there are other elements too that make
come alive in my mind um
not a slam dunk um you get the sense
that
there are very different opinions about
kamala from within the democratic party
it's not a situation where hillary
clinton this is a very big distinction
hillary clinton knew everyone in the
democratic party and most everyone who
was a capital establishment was like
yeah we're doing this hillary thing and
kamala doesn't have anywhere near the
same level of unanimity
she had a long time team but that team
has been kind of broken up around her
and as she's been put into the white
house she's been surrounded by
essentially a subset of biden folks yeah
and so if she were to run for president
then it would be
uh a group of people that haven't really
been through
that many campaigns or wars together
do you think the
i'm not curious is how much does race
and gender play into her
polls dropping from buying to me she's
like an establishment establishment dem
so you'd think that polls would be
relatively similar
uh
now i have other thoughts on com i
didn't think she ran a great campaign i
thought
we ran a much more
savvy and like effective campaign um
thoughts on that or is that looking into
it too much or um well the big thing
about her
uh race and gender is that it's going to
be extraordinarily difficult for anyone
to say you know what it's not comaly
it's me
whoever that person happens to be a
particularly that person's a white man
because then there are the optics of
shoving aside the woman of color so that
you run so there's there's a very big no
one wants to be that guy yeah no no one
wants to be that person if you know of
course if you're another woman of color
then that dynamic goes away
um but i i and this is a very very
fascinating thing where i think if you
were to draw it up
joe even said at one point i'm the
bridge the next generation so after joe
gets in there and then joe passes the
baton to his vp the democratic party
rallies behind the vp and the vp happens
to be
a woman of color and so there would be a
group of people that are very excited
about that and the capital b but in this
is like but kamala consistently polls
worse than joe
and doesn't really have that powerful
and organic connection with like a a lot
of people and to the extent that she was
in the presidential crucible as a
candidate it didn't go that well so
those are your data points then you're
looking at being like okay this seems
like a highly highly risky move to
consolidate behind kamala so after joe
and kamala
then you can try and select someone as
the next figure but here's the thing
the party can't just turn around and
appoint
amy klobuchar or pete and say hey you're
going to be our nominee there'd have to
be a competitive primary
and then if you have that competitive
primary issue number one is joe's still
there and then so you could say well
joe's like hey i'm not going to run
again so go ahead and have a competitive
primary but then kamala is there and so
if you have a competitive primary i
believe that the democrats will not want
to have a competitive primary
particularly in the face of
donald trump and so that brings you back
to joe
i think it's most likely going to be joe
with the major caveat again being health
is that
if you're
81 years old and if joe does run for
president
he'll be the incumbent and so there's
not going to be necessarily like a whole
lot of uh campaigning and travel
involved i mean you could do a lot of it
sort of
uh
[Music]
bought from the white house or tv style
or or what not and maybe you send
surrogates around the country
um but i think that's a difficult and he
does have air force one i mean you know
i've never been on but it seems like a
great way to travel yeah it seems pretty
nice um so if you map this out
it it's probably
trump versus biden again but one of the
things that bill maher said is that if
you dig into it according to bill
it's not that important who the dems run
because
trump will either
win outright i don't know if bill said
that um but he'll say he said trump is
going to ignore vote totals and claim
victory regardless correct
[Music]
this one's gonna make some people very
very happy because you sleep on it
imagine melding technology and
mattresses and if those two things came
together you'd wind up with helix sleep
helix sleep sent me a mattress and i
gotta say it became the favorite
mattress in the entire freaking house
where everyone's just like oh freaking
get out of my way let me get on that
mattress you take a quiz ahead of time
it's customized to you
it's like your own personalized mattress
you'll sleep better you'll feel better
then you'll wake up ready to go
if this sounds like magic to you go to
helixsleep.com
yang take their two minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you with a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life this is the best
overall number one mattress pick of 2020
by gqn wired
chiropractors love it doctors love it i
gotta say this is something where
it's a really smart investment because
you sleep on it every day like i i've
always been a believer in investing in a
good mattress you won't be sorry and
helix is offering up to 200 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners go to helixsleep.com yang
and get that free stuff and 200 bucks
off you won't be disappointed helix
sleep is the bomb
[Music]
so
and bill alluded this too look he said
most things we had been talking about
and i'm glad we're talking about this uh
it feels like
the republicans are playing a different
game than the democrats the democrats
are still in the fantasy world that this
is a normal election that the country's
not in crisis that um and it's gotten
worse like we played a different game
and had a good amount of success when we
ran
in 2020 because we knew the game had
changed and we knew that the traditional
that people are angry
there's financial security and distrust
across the country
the traditional gate people keepers of
political power are they're not broken
but they're cracking um which be it the
media or elected officials or go down
the list
um the republicans have
somewhat figured that out and lined up
behind the donald for better or for
worse in many ways for worse um
the democrats are not they're still like
good old joe well this is the tough and
this is one of the things i the the
republicans have taken on this
anti-institutionalist fervor yeah and it
has a lot of power and
uh potency to it because people are
looking up saying yeah [ __ ] sucks these
people are lying
uh it's all [ __ ] let's tear it down
let's break it up here's the guy who's
going to come and
uh
come and represent that
that group that set of beliefs
and then the democrats
are defending these fading institutions
saying like no it's working
uh give us a chance
um you're you're awful you're terrible
the problem is the institutions do have
real problems
it was an easier case to make when trump
was in charge say hey put us in charge
then things will go well and then now
there's going to be this vibe it's like
well you are in charge and i'm not
loving life like you know life still
kind of sucks
so
it if you look at the
anti-institutionalist fervor versus the
defend the fading establishments i it's
hard to imagine
the latter prevailing
uh decisively
uh or in perpetuity you know i mean
right now the pendulum is swinging back
and forth and people are just pissed off
and and this time they're going to be
pissed off at the party
in power
so the democrats are going to be casting
about for an option maybe or maybe
they're just going to settle on joe
depending
i'm going to just throw out a a figure
just because i was thinking about who if
i were the democrats i would consider
running but again you can't choose the
person they have to go through a
competitive primary and the whole thing
is like you know it's uh who's your pick
who's your dark horse
my dark horse
is
senator john ossoff from georgia wow
because he's young he's social media
savvy
uh he's freaking clean as a whistle-like
guy but you know like that there's
really not much
um like he he hasn't been around the
system long enough to
really have developed that much he
reminds me a bit of obama when he first
ran where he'd been a senator for like
one two years and then people like oh
there's too much too soon and then we're
like yeah we kind of like this
like that would be the kind of dice role
i would consider making if i were the
democrats but again you can't
just choose that uh you know you'd have
to go through a competitive primary i
have no idea if john would decide to run
etc etc but i'm just like throwing out
their like variables
because most people when they think
about the democrats they're only going
to think about the folks who ran for
president last time
stacey abrams
thinks she makes a play
stacey abrams i think she should have to
win her race in 22
and then i don't think it's i don't
think she can just turn around and run
from georgia and in 23 in that way it's
sort of easier if you're already in like
dc i think
but hey you know who knows um
if you were the dems i would consider
looking around a little bit
i suppose but again the dynamics cut
very very heavily against that because
joe's going to be incumbent
kamala is the logical next person
uh and you're going to start with those
two
probably joe
so i guess this is the question you kind
of answer this but i'm curious like what
so bill painted
a dark picture right he talked about the
one of the things that trump has been
doing for one of the first times in his
career is like behind the scenes because
you normally in front of camera
uh setting up the infrastructure so that
he can win no matter what he's toppling
secretaries of state right in various
red states who didn't just find votes
for him or certify uh results right so
apparently 13 of 15 republican
secretaries of state in battleground
states of those um
or of the 15 only two concede that biden
actually won there's 13 of them that are
just said trump won so that's like what
we're talking about and he'll
theoretically and most likely call on
them in 2024
if you're the democrats what do you do
and i think you're saying they should
have the open primary um and start
looking into the bench because this
doesn't look good to me these people are
established so if they're not beating
trump now
it's not gonna
i don't see it getting like you're
looking at the polls in 2022 2023 i
don't see it in a world where it gets
better by election day i don't know what
you think
all right uh and so this was also bill's
point which i agree with is like look um
you're going to be arguing about the
wrong things and even just now i double
down on arguing about the wrong things
which is like swapping candidates yeah
it probably it probably doesn't matter
in the sense that
the vote totals may not matter
what's going to matter is whether the
machinery of our democracy actually
has the credibility
with a critical mass of people to send
everyone home
and
it probably will not uh if
the
quote unquote like you know loser
opponent just refuses to accept results
and there are tens of millions of people
who
are with that person
and and that's what happens when you
have a collapse of trust in a society
correct i mean there's needed to be more
trust so if you're the democrats
what do you do to try and prevent
calamity uh the single best thing you
can do is to
federalize uh some aspects of this
election security and integrity
and this there are there are bills that
are on the table right now to do this
and they are running a ground of the u.s
senate and the filibuster rules where
right now all the dems are into them
except they can't get through
a filibuster they don't have the votes
and and so in order to pass some of this
election integrity stuff you would need
for kirsten cinema and joe manchin to
actually say
yes we're going to wave the filibuster
just to protect our elections
and there are a lot of people that very
much want them to do this another
possibility is that 10 republican
senators like mitt romney and the crew
stand up and say you know what i'm
actually going to go with the democrats
in terms of election elections integrity
and security uh so in other words what
you do is you take the results uh
um
and have some kind of national
verification uh and standard as opposed
to just leaving everything
um
to
local authorities
uh and
this you'd think i don't know if you're
listening to this and thinking like i
totally think we should do this um i'm
going to share something that's not
public knowledge but i'm going to share
it
i was actually
with kirsten cinema not with but like
you know in in the same place
uh last week and she was asked directly
hey what do you think about this issue
and she said that you know the the
filibuster is not something that she is
going to
uh break
uh even for election integrity
so it seems like you are left looking
for 10 republicans
so
when you talk about federalizing our
elections or federally protecting our
elections how
is that instead of giving it to local
authorities local states to administer
elections and ballots things like that
that's giving the power of the federal
government how's that work
so what you want to have at the state
level is non-partisan officials who
essentially say yeah this is what the
result was right
and at least in some of these states
they're saying no let's just give it to
the
state legislators to decide what the
election result was which i'm going to
suggest is probably not the way you want
to go it's like you know because right
you don't want democrats yeah who's more
political than the freaking like
literally like the political actors if
there's people paid to be non-partisan
that does tend to work or you know or a
lot of our even the volunteers are very
very strict um some of that anyway so
what there is is uh in a proposal that's
in the senate right now they want to
establish federal protections to
insulate
nonpartisan state and local officials
who can administer federal elections and
not get bullied
uh insulate which how does that work
probably means they can't get fired got
it
so oh yeah you're working for a
republican secretary of state
pressuring you a certain way
yeah
got it so that i would i you know i
think is pretty common sense again you
don't want folks whose jobs uh depend
upon them
saying a certain result happened yeah
so this is something that you want to
have
passed
and right now it's running aground or
the filibuster and the fact that we have
this duopoly
where this seems somehow partisan
and
because if you're a republican senator
you're looking at this and then if you
vote for it even though i'm going to
suggest it is pretty common sense and if
you believe in democracy you should be
like sure like let's just not i'm sure
the progressives or some far left wing
of the party will throw something in
there that ticks off the right and then
you could turn it down without you know
for on basis of that not everything else
i mean there's a million reasons in the
dilopoli why people end up
turning down rational bills on a high
level at least
yes so that's the situation
there are all these calls now in the
national media to try and exhort
moderate republicans to get with the
program and try and protect our
elections right i agree with this i
think that we should
uh there was an op-ed in the washington
post that was essentially begging some
republicans to do this there's a new new
york times story about republicans
saying we should support democrats in
some cases
uh if it's going to help
the country
survive during this time they're
essentially never trumpers
they say they were considering starting
a third party which sounds familiar but
they decided to go with this
direction
um so if i were the democrats or what i
would be do and the thing is democrats
can't do this which is one reason why
the forward party is necessary and why
we're going to do it or
push the resources necessary to
hopefully get this done but what so the
the problem democrats have there i mean
there are a lot of problems but like the
systems
aren't strong enough and democrats try
and cast this as like defeating
republicans and there are two issues
number one you may not be able to defeat
them uh in the right places via just
vote totals and number two it may not
matter so those are the two things you
want to try and get right and too many
democrats just stay fixated on number
one
they just think like you know what it is
is we just have to defeat them more
soundly give us more money give us more
votes and it's like okay
you may be missing the point
and by the way that plan might not even
work because and you just might not get
as many votes as the other other side
so when you look at number two how do
you make the system and the structure
more genuinely resilient and
representative and lowercase d
democratic like actually responsive to
the will of the people so that's where
something like open primaries and ranked
choice voting would come in
and to me this is where we should be
running running running now walking to
say look we've got one cycle 2022 to try
and make real changes in a system that
would enable a critical mass of
legislators to have some genuine
independence and be able to act on
principle or patriotism and not
partisanship right so let's try and
lighten up the partisan motivations as
quickly as possible and we can actually
do it if we were to pass ballot
initiatives in a number of states
[Music]
here on ford one of the things we're all
about is protecting your data
seeing to it that
it's not like you can be pushed into
everything under the sun can't be spied
on and one very very practical and real
way to do it is to go online using
what's called a virtual private network
and the vpn that we recommend here at
ford's expressvpn it's an app that
connects you securely to another server
and then you can surf around and no one
can see what you're doing it's like
you're getting beamed in to a computer
on the other side of the world seriously
i know
so if you want your surfing to be
private and secure
protect your online activity today with
the vpn rated number one by cnet we've
got an exclusive link for you
expressvpn.com get an extra three months
free on a one year package that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com yang
expressvpn.com to learn more
[Music]
in a way
the problem biltmore identified
was what you've been trying to solve for
since starting the third starting fourth
party for an entire ten days yeah that's
true yeah i mean i've been you know
working on different things yeah
like the problem you identified in your
book is actually what bill maher is
talking about like this is how this
plays out which is a form of a civil war
well we have a very very fragile system
and this is one of the things i want to
convey to folks
is that
our founding fathers if they woke up
they would be shocked and horrified that
we have this
terrible terribly dysfunctional duopoly
because it's so vulnerable
if you have an authoritarian leader who
takes control of one of the major
parties all of a sudden there are no
safeguards because the founding fathers
never imagined a party at this scale
and they wouldn't think that everyone
would just fall in line but that's where
all their political incentives are to
fall in line if you don't fall in line
you lose your job
so the
path out would be to make it so that you
don't just have two parties you have
five parties you have seven parties like
germany where then if one party loses
its [ __ ]
it's a problem but it's not an
existential problem right like that's
what you want to do you want to try and
make the system more resilient so in a
way it'd be like very zen-e now
democrats don't think this way but they
should
is that if you look and say hey what's
the problem okay i think this uh guy's
coming and and he's a jerk and uh it's
gonna be terrible if he wins so
let's defeat him it's like well it's not
quite the problem it's like okay let's
try and make it so that the system is
more dynamic more representative
partisanship doesn't govern republicans
and democrats alike
would be
able to actually exercise their judgment
more third party fourth party would
emerge uh that this is like a democracy
reform package and the problem is that
democrats because they're partisans
don't think in terms of democracy reform
they think just in terms of just beat
the other team
do you think we have enough time to do
this and if not
is the best thing we can do is
to more people primary
or enter the democratic primary
or you know if we don't let's say you
don't get enough
third party representation or open
primaries and local elections
so this is where it kind of gets
interesting so the number one is trying
to make the system more resilient and
dynamic and sustainable and we have one
election cycle to do it right so in an
ideal world we pass
open primaries and rank choice voting
and and
let's call it i'm going to be ambitious
and aggressive
eight states
and then all of a sudden you have 16
senators who look up and be like hey i
can actually do what i want now because
i don't need to go through the hyper
partisan 20
republican primary uh or democratic
primary uh i can appeal to the broad
population right at that point i think
you'd see a lot more people interested
in election integrity and whatnot
because it would seem less
uh partisan yeah
right so that that's playing number one
that's plan number one plan number two
let's say we get two states not enough
senators
yes
uh or you know i mean or none i mean oh
no yeah really really hard yeah like a
grand total of one has ever happened so
you know like you hope you get
some non-zero number but zero is a
possibility so let's prevent that
forwardparty.com let's go get it let's
try and push some of these states across
the finish line
so let's just play out the 24 scenario
and it really does
raise a specter of something very very
rough approaching that time because you
can imagine trump having these dark
rallies around the country and then the
democrats potentially violent rallies
yeah potentially violent rallies
and so one of the things i'm going to
suggest to the world
is that you have democrats representing
the fading establishment you have
republicans representing this
anti-institutional fervor and what you
want is you still want a dynamic change
right you want someone to result
you want someone to represent
the rejuvenation of institutions
like a positive outsiderness
like positive populism in a way yes
positive populism benevolent
transformation something where you don't
pretend that the institutions are
working or that they're somehow going to
uh reform themselves
so you're like a positive reform
movement right that can absorb at least
some of the
uh energy out there like provide a
different path and course and narrative
but also absorb some of the
anti-institutional energy and channel in
a positive way right now
and this is one thing that does drive me
a little bit nuts where you know start
the forward party and like what's the
number one thing yeah you're going to
[ __ ] it up you're going to like get
trouble
it's like well there's so many things
that i have to unpack about this number
one we're focused on 2022 so let's try
and get that done uh but then there's
like this
then if you do fast forward to 24 and
i'm not saying that
that i'm going to run necessarily
but if you look at two candidates
average or the average age between the
two of them i think would be 78 years
old joe will be 81 trump will be 77 so
it'd be 79 i guess
uh
you know i do think that there's going
to be a real gap in the market
like like i think if someone were to run
in a
from a third party i think they'd start
out with
10 15
something along those lines pretty quick
uh
and
i'm going to suggest that that might not
be
something
you mind if you're
the democrats because i think the
democrats might have like a really tough
position that they're defending
you know it's like where if you and so
this is one of the things where you like
shake your head where like democrats
seem to think that every vote comes from
them you know and it it's like at this
point there are a lot of people who are
unhappy that are looking for an
alternative and if you had let's say i'm
just going to throw this out there like
a mark cuban figure i think he gets a
ton of votes and i think he gets a ton
of votes from
people who
were going to vote for trump otherwise
right
um whoever runs i think will probably be
more anti-trump than anti-biden not sure
but that tends to be i think
schultz and bloomberg and cuban the
types that have
explored this probably lean that way um
so
who knows but that is the plan um
no is there a third option
that the democrats start doing better
like getting like their approvals are up
and they actually can win because
the majority of american people are
satisfied with the job performance oh
yeah i i think that that's possible but
i'm not optimistic and here's why
so there was a uh politico journalist
who said something that really stuck
with me he said that where there's a
danger we're entering this post-modern
era of politics where
it doesn't really matter what i do it
just matters what people are hearing and
their part is in spin bubbles
where you like to believe that facts on
the ground will influence
how people feel and how people vote and
unfortunately i think we're in like a an
era where that might not be as true as
you'd hope right like a lot of uh the
feelings and messages that people have
are getting filtered through the media
in various ways
and
i think people are developing a sense of
this administration and that even if a
bunch of legislation gets passed like
that
that the dynamic wouldn't necessarily
revert i mean could things get better
for democrats of course like these
elections are a long way away a lot of
things can happen a lot of variables
um but at this point and this is one of
the reasons why the forward party is so
important is that the polarization is so
extreme that you're not trafficking in
facts anymore for a lot of people like
they're just you know hey i'm pissed off
this [ __ ] sucks like who's in power vote
vote these bums out you know like i gave
them a chance and that you know it's not
really like that's the way a lot of
people feel
even with
this child tax credit which by the way i
love i love love love the child task
because the best thing the government's
done ever
um that like there are a lot of people
that don't realize uh who to thank which
in this case that that was 100 dams like
like the dems freaking past that thing
um and so if i were the dems i would be
jumping up and down every 15th of the
month saying you know that check you're
getting like that's us that's us like
every freaking month if i were joe biden
i'd be like a child tax credit it's us
love it every rep have an event in your
community find some recipient which is
not going to be hard because they're
like 70 million americans that are
benefiting from it just find someone
who's getting the child tax credit just
hammer that message say like this is us
this is us
uh but but right now like that sort of
communication is not happening and i i
think that there there is like a real
uh negativity that's setting it right uh
politico and morning consult came out
with poll the other day it had
less than 40 of respondents of this poll
said that the child tax credit had a
major impact on their lives of the you
know those that have received it and
then half of them 47 credited the
democrats for passing it but only 38
credited joe biden
uh
that disconnect
no one really knows i mean there's many
people are speculating no one really
knows why it's probably to your point
these either partisan spin bubbles or
disinformation bubbles that are
everywhere but on both sides um they
should be hammering this message yeah
you know joe again 15th of every month
to stand up there give a speech be like
with some families be like got the child
tax credit yeah love it best thing i've
done love it you know get that 38 up get
it up to yup
you know above 50 and then you have a
better argument but this is like
so one of the things i i almost tweeted
out the other day and this is something
i do feel
politicians
take credit for things all the time that
have nothing to do with and they take
blame for things they had nothing to do
with too yeah and so that that's really
what's happening in a lot of these
lights
like
you look at the mess on the border i
mean these awful scenes and people like
oh trump's gone the border will get
better it's like the border is a mess
regardless of who's in charge like they
can't recruit people to actually work in
the u.s border patrol because by the way
it's like the shittiest job in the world
in the middle of nowhere that pays less
than other federal jobs and oh by the
way what are you doing like corralling
uh you know migrants who are coming in
it's like does that sound like a job
that you know like right you burn out on
it like you know like a minute and so
then you put joe in charge and
everyone's like what there are still
problems there and you know
like yeah of course they're going to be
problems there it's like like the
problem is that there's like this myth
that you know oh i put you in charge and
all of a sudden like you know like
you're you're going to make it better
because you're a nice person and the
other person's not a nice person it's
like no the problem is that you have
deep thorny problems and really
ineffective bureaucracies that aren't
delivering and if i put like a a
different person in charge like you
still have a lot of the same problems
and and so that that's why
it this is one of the big reasons why
things are getting so nasty here is that
we're all just fed up and frustrated
like value's not being delivered you
have these completely impersonal
bureaucracies that are just you know
failing and then
and and we act like it's like you know
why it's failing because that person's
an [ __ ] yeah and then we put you in
charge and then it's like oh you mean
it's still failing oh [ __ ] and then like
and then like you know i mean phillip
howard called us like we're playing you
lose i lose you lose i lose while the
people lose right um and during that
entire period our trust is just going
down and down and down and down
down and out
and that's where we are
now i mean to me the big antidotes to
this are multi-polar political system
open primaries ranked choice voting and
then universal basic income because i
can actually deliver that i can get you
the check i can't make these shitty
bureaucracies work better overnight but
i can get you that money in your account
you know we have to start
being honest and stop bullshitting about
what we can and can't do
[Music]
all right we're going to talk about
modernity
environmentalism
and tushy
oh it's true a lot of other countries
have figured out that it's easier
on everyone if you use some water
instead of toilet paper and that's what
tushy does it's a modern bidet it just
gets affixed to your toilet i know i
know it's a little bit funny but it's
also a lot awesome it's one reason why
i'm very happy to talk tushy on the pod
tushy is practical it can reduce your
toilet paper use by 80 percent it saves
you money over time it's good for the
planet if this sounds good to you start
washing with tushy go to hellotushy.com
yang to get 10 off plus free shipping
again that's
hellotushi.com for 10 off and after you
buy and install it you can show it off
you can tag it on hellotushi on
instagram and then they will be very
happy with you but it's good for you
good for the planet good for everyone
[Music]
let me ask you this
i don't know if there's a better i don't
think there's a better example of this
so donald trump in 2016 what did he run
on build the wall drain the swamp
essentially right and then maybe you
could argue like a middle finger to the
political lock her up right yeah
anti-hillary right
when he was in bauer with a republican
house and senate right
didn't really pass much a pass a tax
cut for the rich um
and they kind of rolled back some
obamacare stuff they stacked a lot of
courts they loved it they stopped but
they did the courts true um
which is a big thing um
but we didn't build the wall really
still have issues on the border
and we
[Music]
um however his approval rating have gone
up since he left he still has this
massive army people still think he won
he got more votes in 2020
i think to your point earlier that the
facts on the ground don't matter i think
that's kind of where we're at right and
and this is one of the things that i and
i say this in my book because i was
right adjacent to these races
where he got a ton more votes
in districts around the country
uh where again republicans picked up 12
seats
and so this is one of the things where i
saw it was like oh my gosh like there's
like this rising enthusiasm
for him and i thought that going into
november 2020 that trump was at his
worst like covid was beat up and it just
seemed like you know like this is
totally the wrong guy for the job uh and
despite that he got millions more votes
i think he had 75 million votes and
there were states he was supposed to get
stomped in he did not he either almost
won or did win pennsylvania being one of
them um a lot of the swing states he was
super close even if he didn't win it
yeah and this really had an impact on me
where like the forces are rising on that
side
uh and i i do think that this period
uh is going to make many it's going to
disappear a lot of democratic voters i i
you know and it's it's going to energize
people who are still
angry um you know and
there is like uh you and i are sports
fans you know the entire
a guy gets traded and he comes back and
plays against his old team and there's
like always the revenge
and and when that happens
am i the only one who thinks that that
player tends to over perform like oh
yeah they're taking off it's like it's
like the guy who gets breaks up or gets
dumped
and then you know loses 20 pounds and
gets in shape and fix his hair and just
looks like you know
[Music]
we've been there
trump's going to have that kind of
payback energy right
yeah
um and so his supporters yeah um that
felt like they're robbed it's
well my fear is um
what starts happening in practice um
because there's stuff i've always like
leaned a little more conservative on i
think free markets and government are
usually better than whatever government
bureaucracy or too many rules are
created but
then you look at the texas abortion law
and some of the things that the
republicans win in power start doing and
you're like
i mean there's no way to look at that
law there's even like decently
conservative republicans they're like
that law's [ __ ] up um
and that's my fear what this starts
happening because i don't think trump
has a grip on that um
i don't have grip a lot of things i
think but um
you know like that's where i think this
pla that's what we're i think fighting
for it's like these kind of backwards
policies that aren't getting past when
you end up
with that party in charge and not um
well it's called strong leadership at
the top
well we we
may be in position to find out if we
don't see something
that changes the dynamic um you thinking
in 22 or 24 like 24 if they were to
assume power are you thinking in states
around the country so i think it's
it's both right like bill maher was
talking about how you'll have
it's like the ripple effect of this it's
not just the presidency you've got
wisconsin pennsylvania and michigan gov
governor races all happening which me
and he predicts
two of those will go red um
which means when a gov when a one
there's a red governor that usually
means you have state legislators and
house and senate seats going red as well
they usually follow the top of the
ticket like that
and then you end up
i don't know i think on a congressional
level it looks like 2022 you'll probably
end up with just dysfunction and
like the kind of gridlock again but
if you end up with this trump movement
again
i don't know and then just what happens
in 2028 um
things seem to be getting worse not
better so one thing we didn't talk about
is the composition of the u.s senate
so
75 percent chance approximately
according to the markets that
republicans retake the house in 22.
right now the senate's tied 50 50.
the senate map is not bad for democrats
in 22.
there is a real chance that they
stay tied uh lose one seat gain one seat
like it's around that order of magnitude
uh for
democrats
in 22 24
uh then the the dynamic is a bit tougher
um of course you know it's gonna going
to be during a national election so it's
unclear right um but that this is
so the
the one of the things i i'd say and this
is funny because like i'm an optimistic
upbeat guy i'm can do like you know
trying to make positive things happen
you got to try and strengthen the system
and increase our reasonableness and um
reward
uh folks who are
you know like avoiding um
like
you know insane positions in the rest of
it
but
the the the problem
we have to grapple with is that like our
our institutions are corroding
and we're at a point in american life
where everything is possible
and when i mean that i generally mean
that negatively it's like whatever dark
crazy scenario you can imagine it is on
the table you know you should take it
very very seriously yes and if you doubt
that then just rewind over the last
number of months and think about the
darkest things that you have seen happen
here in america and many of those things
would have been unthinkable
just
x
months prior
you know january 6th uh
the violence of the preceding year
uh george floyd dying before our eyes
like you know pandemic obviously
beat up on the street in new york city
yeah just uh
so so like the pro like any unthinkable
stuff you can imagine
is on the table
now one of the things i'm going to
suggest is that everything could be on
the table positively
two if enough of us got together like
people say like oh four party third
party can't happen it's like well 62
percent of people want an alternative so
enough of us get together like we could
probably do something that's never been
done before universal-based kingdom
impossible it's like well at this point
like two-thirds of americans want that
too and like we only have versions of it
like good things
can be done also much more quickly than
people imagine
but right now the
prevailing forces are leading us towards
like incredibly negative things
happening everything should be on the
table that maybe that that could be a
takeaway from today is that everything
should be on the table and when you look
at 2024 and you just think oh like this
person when that person win
bill maher and others robert kagan and
others are correct that this actually
could be
unprecedented
uh and
not follow the script at all
in terms of people staying at home and
saying okay that's what happened and
then going on with their lives the next
day you sound like tristan harris who
said the internet is the ability to
create
utopia and dystopia like that and it's
deciding which way we go um and your
point and we've learned this we've all
learned this is that it happens it's to
happen way faster than things normally
happen right you get a massive massive
change in a matter of
months and years and not
you know decades and centuries in in
ways so yeah i just got to use it for
the good got to use this this time
acceleration
factor for the good and not just the bad
so podcast of action number one
forwardparty.com yes you're doing a lot
of and it's a ton of the local work
which i i'm like a fan of and two
you're on bill maher
next friday i am but i'm going to
chicago atlanta denver
california sf la
that's it eventually iowa
[Music]
iowa you're on the road yang's on the
road
yeah
so
that's what you're we're not just
i just don't this podcast isn't one
where we just complain on it all the
time we can complain with action around
it yeah i don't have it in me to just be
like oh someone do that and then go and
don't like chill out because especially
now because i'm
someone who actually might be able to
move the needle on these issues to a
higher which i thank everyone who's
listening to this or watching this
because you make it so
uh but yeah like there aren't that many
people who who can help
modernize things to a point where we can
get through this time and i i believe i
can help so i'm gonna do my best so yeah
we're just not talking it man we're
trying to walk the walk here we are all
right guys thank you for tuning in
forward ho
forward
[Music]
we need like a exit music so we can
outro ouch hit that outro outro baby
[Music]
you